Knockout has another kind of model data object, called, a Computed Observable.
Computed observables are really nice, because they can create a value when
they're accessed, rather than just retrieve it from somewhere.
One good example is fullName.
That should take your first name and
your last name, combine them together, and return it.
Maybe if there's a middle name defined, it should add that in too.
Now, it doesn't make any sense to store the fullName as an actual string here,
because that's redundant.
We already have all of the information we need, to figure out the full name.
So, rather than store it as a string, why not store it as an action,
as a function?
So, that's exactly what we do.
We store fullName as a special kind of function, and
when you want to get the full name, you run that function, and
it returns the first name plus a space, plus the last name.
The great thing is, when all of your variables are observables, or
computed observables, you can treat them all exactly the same.
So, it's just as easy for us to use, but we get the benefit of having
a data object that computes itself, based on other data that we're storing.